we mentioned nuclear quite a few times
yeah that you know there was a for a
long time it seems to have shifted
recently maybe you can clarify and
educate me on this but there for the
longest time people thought that nuclear
is um
is almost unclean energy or dangerous
energy or all that kind of stuff when
did that shift what was the source of
that alarmism
uh and what maybe is that a case study
of how alarmism can turn into
um the productive constructive policy
productive from whose standpoint
um is it not is it not like uh nuclear
we're not trying to do you mean
productive in terms of yay we banned it
or protect it for them oh I see I see
what you mean yes I meant productive for
human civilization no the alarmism over
nuclear power dominated any alarmism
over global warming
absolutely yeah really oh yeah is this
in the United States um Three Mile
Island then you turn Chernobyl there
and the traditional environmental
movement will still won't go there they
still
the big groups nrdc edfs that whole
alphabet soup of the big greens are
reluctant to put forward the nuclear
option because they know a lot of their
aging donors
basically grew up in the thinking about
nuclear as as the problem not the
solution I lived for the last 30 years I
moved to Maine recently uh
but I lived in Hudson Valley 10 miles
from the Indian Point Nuclear Power
Plant which is built in the 60s 70s
and had some problems none of them were
to the point of
a meltdown or the threat of it or even
the theoretical possibility of one
I've been I was in it twice as a
reporter you know looking down in the
cooling pool I can send you a fun video
of bubbles in the cooling pool with the
rods and
progressively they demonstrated how to
handle waste in the United States now
the waste is uh because we haven't
figured out how to move it across state
lines
it's uh
glassified it's put into kind of
containers that sit there at the plant
we just simply don't have a long-term
solution
um
the Nevada
uh politicians were successful in saying
not here not here not Yucca Mountain and
um
but my wife who I've been married to
well I met 30 years ago and she lives
with me she's an environmental educator
she was very happy when Cuomo shut it
down
said we're going to shut it down three
or three or four years ago which just
happened a year it actually is shut down
now it's being mothballed and I was like
that sucks
we need if she's happy yeah and we still
love each other she's environmentalist
so that that just speaks to a lot of
environmentals still see nuclear as bad
oh totally oh yeah you know and you
bring in the way the weapons
proliferation issues and but it's a
safety thing it's a generational thing I
think young people are different I hope
these small modular reactor designs
several of which there's a couple of
phds from
MIT who did transatomic power they're
both like in their early 30s we need so
much more of them and just briefly the
one thing I say about nuclear is like
with so many of these things like
subsidies don't talk to me about yes no
nuclear talk to me about what do you
want to do with existing nuclear power
plants
and what do you want to do about the
possibility of new ones
let's parse this out in chunks that we
can have constructive conversations
about the idea of no nuclear drives me
crazy just like no fossil fuel subsidies
is silly in the world we have it that
has these pockets of no energy so that
that's just my you know my sustain what
mantras
start with some dividing it and divide
and conquer to conquer the dispute over
by saying let's at least get real this
power plant has been in the Hudson
Valley for 30 years it was the base load
it was based base load is the real thing
and guess what has filled the Gap since
that power plant is turned off
natural gas natural gas but and if you
don't hear that from the environmental
community that was so eager to turn off
the Indian Point I I think both the
point of you know saying that people are
saying it's the end of the world but no
I don't want a new clip it just doesn't
make sense right um and and Andy's
absolutely right to talk about so
existing new clip power plants we
already paid for them we already have
them we already committed to
decommissioning them eventually while
they're running they're pretty much the
cheapest power you can possibly have on
the planet because it costs almost
nothing to run them day to day so you
know it's basically cheap or almost free
CO2 baseload power there's just nothing
there that is that doesn't you know you
you should embrace now new nuclear power
plants turn out to be very expensive
currently so you know the one they built
in Finland and some and and and and the
UK and France and several other places
turn out to be incredibly expensive so
they're much more expensive than you
know the the the costliest uh Renewables
you can imagine so they're actually not
a solution right now
and that's why we need the Innovation
that's why we need the potentially
fourth generation new clip how it's just
simply it's a bad deal and that's why
you know nuclear is never going to win
on its third generation now it may never
get there you know who knows but it's
certainly a a a a a a possibility and we
should be looking into it and there are
there are you know wonky realities that
need to be dealt with the nuclear
Regulatory Commission in the United
States their approval process is still
locked and designed on this 50 year old
model of big giant power plants there's
an intense discussion right now about
evolving a new regulatory scheme for
small modular ones because of all these
implicit advantages they offer and that
so it along with the Innovation you need
to have this
right get out of the way or you're never
going to have the investment so it
really isn't all the above thing and
looking at these systems uh problems
systems Solutions is really important